gewaltige katastrophen die das leben auf
der erde auslöschen passieren solche
geologischen umwälzungen und irdische
katastrophen nicht zufällig sondern nach
einem regelmäßigen zyklus genau das hat
jetzt ein us forschungsteam erforscht
hat unsere erde also eine art
katastrophen pulsschlag und wann droht
uns demnach die nächste mega katastrophe
weg zum science and future gibt drei mal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
massenaussterben extreme veränderung des
meeresspiegels eruptionen von
supervulkan oder aber das ist ein
brechen von super kontinenten gewaltige
katastrophen und geologische umwälzung
der erde die das leben auf ihr
auslöschen die frage ist nicht ob solche
extreme naturereignisse auf unserer erde
stattfinden sondern nur wann
sie gehören einfach mit dazu aber um
besser vorbereitet zu sein und nicht
plötzlich überrascht zu werden suchen
fachleute weltweit intensiv nach zyklen
die große frage also lautet folgen
solcher katastrophen natürlichen
rhythmen wie etwa der lauf der planeten
oder aber die jahreszeiten oder finden
solche katastrophen in rein zufälligen
zeitabständen stadt alles andere als
zufall
diese prothese hatten fachleute bereits
vor vielen jahren aufgestellt und
tatsächlich konnte einen us
forschungsteam nun neue hinweise auf
einen solchen katastrophen puls der erde
aufstellen was steckt dahinter schlummer
tief in unserer erde etwa eine art
katastrophen pulsschlag und falls ja wer
gibt diesem takt vor
die antworten auf all diese spannenden
fragen jetzt mega katastrophen und große
massenaussterben gab es in der
geschichte der erde immer wieder so
beispielsweise eruptionen von hugo
bekannten für folgenreiche katastrophen
und teilweise sogar für massenaussterben
sorgten ein eindrückliches beispiel wenn
man in die geschichte der erde schaut
eine region im westen indiens die vom
vulkanismus geprägt ist dekan trap eine
folge einer vulkanischen super
katastrophe die sich dort vor rund 65
millionen jahren abspielt gigantische
lavamassen wurden ausgeworfen und die
ausbrüche des dick- und raps haben sich
wohl über ein bisschen
millionen jahre erstreckt
zurückgeblieben ist ein achtung 600.000
quadratkilometer großes gebiet das noch
heute von einer bis zu ein oder zwei
kilometer dicken basalt schicht bedeckt
ist also dem ausruf der vulkane
das muss man sich mal vorstellen asche
und gase und gingen bis in die
stratosphäre und die temperaturen auf
der erde sanken weltweit um vier bis
fünf grad schwefel schwefeldioxid und
schwefelwasserstoff wurden in der luft
zu schwefelsäure die folge saurer regen
das chlor das durch den regen aus der
luft ausgewaschen wurde löschte alles
leben in den obersten wasserschichten
von seen und meeren aus zudem kam es zu
einem ozonloch durch die tausenden
tonnen an salzsäure die ihnen die
atmosphäre aufstiegen der großteil des
uv schutz fehlt das der erde wurde damit
zunichte gemacht und pflanzen und tiere
waren der strahlung schutzlos
ausgeliefert nach dem vulkan- winter
folgt dann die hitze dafür sorgte das
kohlendioxid das durch die vulkan in die
atmosphäre geschleudert worden war
das irdische klima heizte sich stück für
stück auf die organismen die hier schon
angeschlagen waren durch die strahlung
und kälte konnten dem wahrscheinlich zum
großteil nicht mehr trotzen so oder
ähnlich hat sich das ganze höchst
wahrscheinlich vor 65 millionen jahren
zugetragen
auch wenn das ganze szenario nicht
eindeutig nachweisbar ist manche
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftler aber
gehen sogar davon aus dass dieser
supervulkan für das ende der dinosaurier
verantwortlich ist und kein
asteroideneinschlag das massensterben am
ende der kreidezeit verursacht hatte
bereits in den 1920 er jahren hatten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die hypothese aufgestellt dass die erde
möglicherweise eine art katastrophen
takt von rund 27 bis 30 millionen jahren
folgt damals wurden vor allem
tektonische großereignisse untersucht
mittlerweile sind die
untersuchungsmethoden deutlich besser
geworden und die wissenschaft kann so
bessere antworten auf ihre fragen
bekommen
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam um
michael rapino von der new york
university in den letzten 25 jahren hat
es sich
die kante verbesserungen bei den
radiologischen kartierungs methoden
gegeben
die fachleute haben einen möglichen
zyklus von irdischen großereignissen nun
nochmal genauer ins visier genommen und
tatsächlich konnten so ereignisse
präziser datiert und frühere veh
lackierung korrigiert werden bei ihrer
suche nach zeitlichen auffälligkeiten
hatten die us wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler außerdem auf
verschiedene statistische methoden zur
hilfe genommen konkret konnten so 89
ereignisse in den vergangenen 2 160
millionen jahren genauer analysiert
werden auch die eruption des dekan traps
war mit dabei ebenso auch die zeiten in
denen sich der meeresspiegel enorm
verändert hat aber auch tektonisch
ereignisse wie das zerbrechen von super
kontinenten wie das legendäre gondwana
sparte das forschungsteam in seiner
analyse nicht aus daraus waren das
heutige afrika und südamerika
hervorgegangen von 250 millionen jahren
existierte der superkontinent pangäa
hier waren alle landmassen der erde
zusammengefasst und vom meer umgeben vor
200 millionen jahren zerfiel pangea in
zwei teile gondwana im süden und laura
sia im norden beide kontinente waren
später dann eben noch in kleinere stücke
zerbrochen
die untersuchung des forschungsteams
präsentiert sich wirklich als sehr
detailreich und tatsächlich die
perspektive über die vergangenen zwei
160 millionen jahre hinweg offenbarte
spannende erkenntnisse demnach scheinen
diese ereignisse alle einem gewissen
zyklus zu folgen und zwar von 26,9 bis
27,5 millionen jahren in diesem rhythmus
gab es also eine reihe von katastrophen
die unsere erde erschütterten konkret
konnte das forschungsteam zehn cluster
ausfindig machen die aus ereignissen mit
globaler bedeutung bestehen diese
cluster eine vergangenen 260 millionen
jahren sind gestaltet wie ein uhrwerk
und liegen jeweils rund 26,9 bis 27,5
millionen jahre auseinander
und nicht nur bei massenaussterben
konnte diese periodizität festgestellt
werden sondern auch bei rein
biologischen ereignissen wie das
forschungsteam in einer aktuellen studie
schreibt der wissenschaftler michael
rapino der an der untersuchung beteiligt
war fasst das so zusammen
viele geologen glauben dass die
zeitliche abfolge geologische ereignisse
völlig
aber unsere studie liefert statistische
belege für einen zugrundeliegenden
zyklus die ergebnisse sprechen dafür
dass die erdgeschichte von größtenteils
periodischen koordinierten und teilweise
katastrophalen ereignissen geprägt ist
eine spektakuläre erkenntnis aus der
zwei fragen folgen welche ursache steckt
hinter diesen katastrophen takt der
offensichtlich tief in der erde
schlummert und können wir aus dieser
studie herleiten wann der erde die
nächste mega katastrophe droht zur
ursache tappen die fachleute tatsächlich
noch im dunkeln doch sie haben eine
vermutung zahlreiche katastrophen egal
ob klimatisch oder biologische art
hängen mit geologischen ereignissen
zusammen beispiele dafür sind
veränderungen des meeresspiegels oder
massenaussterben demnach könnte es also
prozesse im inneren der erde geben die
den takt des planeten bestimmen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
denken hier vor allem an strömungen im
inneren der erde die sich verändern
tiefe strömungen also im flüssigen teil
unserer erde könnten für die schlimmen
verwerfungen auf der erdoberfläche
verantwortlich sein
doch auch eine andere mögliche ursachen
ziehen die fachleute in betracht demnach
könnten es auch kosmische einflüsse
seien vielleicht sind es also
veränderungen der sonneneinstrahlung die
ereignisse auf der erde auslösen die
rede ist hier vom sogenannten wie
lankowitz zyklus dabei handelt es sich
um eine art klimamodell verschiedene
parameter sollen dabei einen einfluss
auf die temperatur und somit das klima
der erde haben der milankovic zyklus
kann nach meinung der wissenschaftler
community auch für die eiszeiten
verantwortlich gemacht werden er ist
demnach möglicherweise in der lage
kürzere schwankung auszulösen
die 27 5 bis 390 millionen jahre dauern
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam
andererseits ist der takt auch nah an
der periode von rund 32 millionen jahren
wenn er das sonnensystem durch die
zentrale ebene unserer galaxie wandert
doch das sind nur mutmaßungen die
ursache die für den katastrophen
pulsschlag der erde verantwortlich sein
könnten bleibt rätselhaft doch dass
dieser pulsschlag existiert davon sind
michael campino und seinem team
überzeugt aber was auch immer die
ursache sein mag das timing der
geologischen großereignisse stützt die
annahme dass es sich hier um eine
rio tische und koordinierte abfolge
handelt eine weitere frage die finalen
nicht geklärt werden kann aber immerhin
eingegrenzt werden kann ist die frage
wann unserer erde
die nächste mega katastrophe droht der
letzte cluster den das forschungsteam
identifizieren konnte liegt etwa zehn
millionen jahre zurück wenn man nach dem
ergebnis der aktuellen studie geht
hätten wir demnach noch etwas mehr als
16 millionen jahre zeit bis das nächste
katastrophale ereignis das leben auf der
erde in gefahr bringt allerdings droht
hier schon die nächste katastrophe
gefahr einer katastrophe fast 100 neue
vulkane entdeckt anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren denn wenn euch dieses thema
auch interessieren dann solltet ihr
unbedingt ein abo da lassen dann gibt es
hier nämlich dreimal pro woche spannende
themen für euch bis dann bleibt dran